am excited to a nervts and tell you are
Plattform with a revolution
sieht aus wie so eine krankenhausbrille
die man nach einer Augen OP bekommt
gestern auf einem Event das neue Vision
pro vorgestellt was so eine Art Brille
Daten Computer im Raum darstellen soll
so sind die Brille auf jeden Fall von
außen aus so von der Seite als ziemlich
beschissen und so sieht's aus wenn man
durch die Brille durchguckt ich weiß
zwar nicht wer sich bei dem Ausblick auf
einen See und ein Berg und ein Wald
seine scheiß Brille aufsetzt aber okay
die Sache ist allerdings dass wir die
Brille bisher noch nicht getragen
an einem Menschen gesehen haben
[Musik]
absolut beschissen aus ich meine
oder auch hier
macht sich doch komplett zum Affen mit
zum Dingen
[Musik]
sieht schön aus
aber ist da die ganze Zeit so ein Kabel
dran
so läuft man dann damit rum
mit einem Kabel von der Brille in deinen
Arsch wo du den Akku in der Tasche hast
wisst ihr woran mich das erinnert an die
elopex aus den avatar-filmen womit die
Menschen da auf diesem Planeten atmen
können 5 Sekunden später
zwei Stunden hält der Akku nur
okay gut ich meine es ist Apples erste
Brille es ist auch generell Apples
erster Schritt in Richtung Alter
deswegen fordern für das Ding natürlich
auch nicht so viel Geld 349
$ soll die Vision pro Kosten
oder anderen Produkten ist es auch
natürlich ein bisschen teurer aber es
ist natürlich
eine Zahl vergessen
349 sondern 3000 499
kann man mit dem Ding fliegen die
Steuerung funktioniert über die Augen
die Stimme und die Hände
was in Navigator
[Musik]
so machen wenn ich irgendwie eine Seite
weiter scrollen will oder was ist Gold
wird bei Vision pro mit den Augen
Objekte auswählen geht per Finger Geste
das heißt ich laufe hier durch Köln
habe diese komische Avatar elopak in der
Fresse und macht dann so
oder oder wie jetzt über eine virtuelle
Tastatur eingegeben werden
[Musik]
perfekt ich kann mich direkt aus Köln
verwandeln
[Musik]
also ich habe ich direkt ein paar mehr
Fragen erstens hier wird es in diesem
Apple Clip so dargestellt in der Werbung
als wenn dann auch ihre Freunde alle
dieses Headset haben und die Dame dann
irgendeiner Präsentation arbeiten also
kein Unternehmen wird sich denken ich
kaufe unsere Angestellten für
präsentationsmeeting jeweils ein 3.500 $
Headset weil dann wäre das Unternehmen
ziemlich schnell pleite Sache Nummer
zwei die ich mich allerdings Frage ist
wie sehen dich denn die anderen Personen
ich meine du hast ja nicht wie so ein
Anglerfisch sondern fette Kamera um
seinen Nacken rum die dich dann von
vorne filmt dein Name France
okay das ist unheimlich experience
[Musik]
diese App habe ich nie verstanden der
größte Rotz warum braucht man eine
verschissene App um runterzukommen bin
ich runterkommen will packe ich mein
Handy weg ich lege mich hin ich mache
meine Augen zu warum braucht man so ein
dummes Gedudel und irgendwelche Blüten
auseinander gehen um runterzukommen also
for real jeder der diese App von euch
benutzt Ciao da ist die Tür
also
[Musik]
meine Mom
hat mir damals gesagt dass ich eckige
Augen kriege wenn ich zu nah vom
Fernseher sitze
das hier
das ist eine ganz andere Liga
unser Fernseher war so groß wie ein
Toaster und ich saß zehn Meter entfernt
und die kommt an mit oh du schielt
später dein ganzes Leben deine Augen
werden eckig aber die hier die sitzt
vorne Kinoleinwand in der aller aller
ersten Reihe immer überlegen wie
schädlich so ein Ding eigentlich für die
Augen ist ne
du guckst ja die ganze Zeit auf einen
Stream direkt
ich mein Problem ich werde mir den
Scheiß eh nicht kaufen aber gut meine
Damen und Herren an der Stelle würde ich
meine wissenschaftlich fundierte Review
der Apple Vision pro ai Brille jetzt
auch beenden das Ding hat nicht nur
Nachteile so wie ich es jetzt
humoristischerweise dargestellt habe
sondern tatsächlich auch ein paar coole
Features wie beispielsweise dass man
damit auch seine Playstation irgendwie
verbinden kann und zocken kann oder auch
Räume die eigentlich nicht offen sind
quasi öffnen lassen kann in Augmented
Reality ich bin sehr gespannt glaub dass
das Ding noch nicht ganz zu Ende gedacht
ist aber apple will vielleicht irgendwie
der erste auf dem Markt sein und
deswegen haben uns jetzt einfach raus
3.500 € verstehe ich überhaupt nicht ich
bin eh Pleite wird mir das Ding nicht
kaufen können jetzt aber auch nicht
machen wenn ich Multimilliardär wer weiß
einfach affig finde
aber auch ab ich also vielleicht kaufe
ich es